peu
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
préfiguration de ce que sera le match de
rugby france gall le drapeau tricolore
supplante le poireau l'emblème des
gallois avant le coup d'envoi donné en
présence de 70000 spectateurs
le match débute mal pour les français
maillot légèrement plus foncé que les
gallois sept minutes de jeu et c'est un
coup franc que réussie morgan maison est
cependant très vite rassuré pour
l'équipe de france qui domine le pays de
galles avec une facilité presque
insolente la troisième ligne française
impose sa manière de jouer à ses
adversaires
pense que manque là et c'est l'oeil à
part tout à la main et marque un très
bel essai que transforme vanier 5
[Applaudissements]
deuxième mi-temps le trois quarts centre
jacky bouquet numéro 13 perse passe le
ballon à albaladejo numéro 10 qui porte
à suivre et mme eric va marquer un
deuxième essai pour la france
huit sacs
[Applaudissements]
et le festival offensif de l'équipe de
france poursuit le ballon vole de mains
en mains la troisième ligne française
continue de donner le ton les deux
nouveaux 2000 accroît et albaladejo
lance attaque sur attaque l'une de ces
attaques se termine par un nouvel essai
marqué par la porte certains de leur
supériorité les français se met à
souffler un peu ils ont tort durant une
dizaine de minutes en effet au cours de
la deuxième mi temps les gallois donnent
le frisson aux supporters français c'est
d'ailleurs le cas en ce moment
gal attaque et bouquets in extremis sur
une situation désespérée finalement
c'est très logiquement que la france
gagne par ses amis
[Applaudissements]
l'union sud-africaine vit aujourd'hui
des heures graves la campagne de
désobéissance civile entreprises par la
population noire pour protester contre
les lois de ségrégation raciale a
commencé dans le 170 morts et 170
blessés dans les rangs des manifestants
tel est le bilan de cette première
journée dramatique
[Musique]
au milieu de cette atmosphère explosive
on voit comment le gouvernement pourrait
maintenir par la force les lois raciales
imaginé par le célèbre docteur mal en
contre lesquels sont dressés désormais
les 11 millions de noirs de l'état sud
africain
[Musique]
première journée de son séjour à paris
n'avait pas épuisé le carnet de rendez
vous de monsieur coach of le lendemain
la foule devait le revoir à l'hôtel de
ville n'est pas en effet d'homme d'état
en visite que la ville de paris ne
tienne à recevoir chez elle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et après avoir visité la salle des
prévôts le président soviétique a
sacrifié à la petite formalité du livre
d'art
à paris monsieur coach of avait aussi
rendez vous dans un deux pièces cuisine
avec le souvenir d'un certain vladimir
oulianov qui avait vécu là pendant trois
ans reçu un demi siècle et que le monde
connaît mieux sous le nom de lénine
le président soviétique devait encore
faire les honneurs de sa table au
général de gaulle une table tous les
plats avaient été soigneusement vérifiés
au pavillon dauphine enfin monsieur
khrouchtchev avait rendez vous avec 250
journalistes petite manifestation
sportive pour laquelle il a un fait
[Applaudissements]
d'un côté
la tendance
voilà ce que les aînés qu'est ce qui
vous a le plus frappé chez le général de
gaulle à quoi ressemble votre lieu chez
ces petites lignes à dire à votre gauche
sam hamad a aussi sollicité
mais on peut tout dire j'ai l'impression
la plus frappante pendant ce temps
madame line un coup de chaud accompagné
de ses filles se livrer à d'autres
occupations culturelle au musée du
louvre où son sourire légendaire
rencontrer celui de la joconde
[Musique]
plus crivoï un peu plus tard dans un
grand magasin où elle a pu apprécier à
sa valeur la bousculade traditionnel
légèrement favorisé il faut le dire par
les photographes
[Musique]
le séjour à paris tirait à sa fin et la
foule parisienne attendait mieux coup de
chauffe et madame linafoot chauvat à
l'opéra où le président de la république
les avait conviés à assister à une
représentation de carmen
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour leur dernière soirée ils avaient
ainsi rendez-vous avec le tout paris
on
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le lendemain commencé à orly ce qu'il
est convenu d'appeler le tour de france
de monsieur khrouchtchev un tour de
france en saint geours
bordeaux était la première étape de ce
voyage
[Applaudissements]
président soviétique de veti trouvaient
à l'hôtel de ville un visage connu le
maire monsieur chaban delmas lui a
récemment rendu visite au kremlin à la
tête d'une délégation de parlementaires
français
petit échange de cadeaux monsieur contre
of ne voulut pas remettre le sien un
fusil de chasse sans indiquer la manière
de s'en servir
mon château de pau où l'accueillait la
municipalité de la cité béarnaise
le président soviétique se retrouvait
avec un agneau sur les bras un cadeau
somme toute embarrassant
[Musique]
en languedoc monsieur coach of devait
visiter la station de pompage de pitbull
pièce principale du système d'irrigation
de la région du barreau
[Musique]
le free cette fois des épis de maïs
l'une de ses passions vite et c'était
nîmes la pluie n'avait pas découragé les
applaudissements
et monsieur coup de chance n'avait pas
perdu son sourire
[Applaudissements]
à
[Musique]
l'armée rouge est à paris pas tout à
fait disons plutôt le commando de choc
du charme slave
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après les chants les danses car cette
formation de 185 artistes en uniforme
possède aussi ses danseurs qui font
preuve d'une stupéfiante virtuosité
acrobatique
[Musique]
il habite
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]